clément gignac économiste en chef de
l'alliance industrielle alliance est
avec nous si gignac bonsoir on a besoin
de vos lumières
je vous présente un certain nombre de
questions qu'on a reçus puis ça fait
vraiment très très bien le tour première
question les akkaya bissonnette vous le
demande je me demandais quelles sont les
conséquences de la pandémie sur
l'économie à court et long terme dans le
monde et pour les canadiens ça c'est
généralement une bonne entrée en matière
mais c'est ce qu'on va où vivait une
contraction de l'activité calmer ce que
nous les économistes son appel récession
c'était le mot récession en cours aux
jeunes même sauvé une récession c'est
pour des prêts sans sa positon tourne
super remontée pour ça que je disais qu
imposerait dans l'économie et le
dépendamment de la réaction des
gouvernements mais ça peut avoir une
plus grosse ou moins d'importance donc
le chômage de rester
on était juste un peu augmenté beaucoup
dépendamment des réactions du domaine là
on est rendu au point de pouvoir les
déclencher cette de sortir le baseball
pour s'assurer qu'elles touchent
marquisienne pour sa combi point
critique a dit oui puis déjà les
washington commencent à sortir le
bazooka demain à ottawa ont annoncé
d'aidé à un plat assez robuste la grande
bretagne également donc on le voit sa
wii déficit budgétaire on circule plus
de 9
le maintenant on pense aux autres mais
on demande aux fonctionnaires on demande
aux gens d'affaires des spécialistes
donnez nous des idées là pour s'assurer
que limiter des pertes d'emplois puis
limité le fait que toute image pour
augmenter s'assurer que quand on
retrouve le fameux vaccin
je suis content à combien de temps
tester comment se faisait que les gens
vont revendre avions afin d'écraser
alors partis qui avaient encore
ecopy y croisait encore de tomber en
riant militaires encore du personnel les
autorités ça va être majeurs ce qui sans
lien selon moi comme intervention jeu
matin qu' on en voit déchets au chant
directement des gens comme vous puis
moins 20 corps prévaloir choléra bourse
l'eau mais on n'est pas bling nous mais
pour ceux qui paient le job des congés
sens des mesures aussi draconiennes lui
valait marcotte safer venu beaucoup
aujourd'hui
est ce qu'il ya une façon de proposer
aux banques et institutions financières
de faire leur part pour les paiements
des hypothèques entre autres pour être
aussi le cas de mehdi pas de risque je
préfère secret des dieux mais je sais
que les contacts avec et le ministre des
finances et on a vu des choses dans
d'autres pays chez cette jeune
britannique tout que les gens qui sont
affectés par le corno virus ou qui
perdent leur emploi sans sol on est en
congé de toi six mois on n'a pas besoin
de payer son hypothèque sur le gardien à
quoi vous payer mais si vous perdez
votre emploi parce qu'on leur donne un
moratoire la dette
vous savez des intérêts capitalisés
mais les voyages de souplesse et des
choses qui existent déjà et je vous
crois pas parce que vous l'êtes
d'habitude à la sarre est de s'en venir
demain on verra durant la très bien
quand chevalier vous demande durant la
pandémie serait-il possible que les
banques suspendu réduisent le taux des
cartes de crédit et le trou des prêts
personnels aux utilisateurs dont les
revenus seront pour plusieurs réduit et
n'est joué et hop et r ils peuvent le
faire mais je serais étonné que ça se
trouvait aussi que le gouvernement les
juges mais c'est une autre paire de
manches et je vais étonner mais qu' on
donne un peu de souplesse quant aux
montants remboursés pour les trois à six
prochains mois
numéro 8
the lauzon de vaudreuil pour les
retraités qui ont de l'argent placé à la
bourse et qui vivent de leurs placements
les chiffres dégringole bientôt nous
n'aurons plus un sou pour notre retraite
quelles sont les chances que ça se
redresse gilles qu'on n'a pas plus
souvent d'un traité at on sait je
corrige si quelqu'un sonne à raison de 5
à 8 ans étaient ceux qui se met jamais
vu que la peau soit plus beau plus tard
si on exclut les années 30 donc l'idée
souvent l'opérateur cette panique et
puis demain tout parce qu'on crise
tourisme perdre
évidemment quand ont été déboursés pour
des voisins séquencé pour changer sur le
tour dans six mois dans un an dans moi
je m'inquiète pas trop là dessus
oui ça va peut-être prendre 6 - mais
est-ce qu'on récupère les pertes mais
qu'est ce qui s'en vient je pense que la
confiance qu'on va venir parce que c'est
faux le système financier s'est effondré
c'est comme si on avait eu un
tremblement terre où est le concepteur
et le que tout à coup ça va prendre 3 6
mois lassé des choses mais on n'est pas
dans les années 30 s'est pas passé ainsi
que c'était cool et et les élus communs
vont intervenir donc en construction on
prend soin de sa famille mais toujours
partie des 400 lits et on travaille
autre main mais clément va se reparler
vous avez accepté de nous parler
régulièrement il ya beaucoup de
questions qui vont entrer mais déjà je
trouve ça lumineux et je dois dire
encourageant ce que vous nous dites
merci clément gignac
à très bientôt au plaisait